irving and now bam switches onto him the
three up in the air
dragons with the board 20 seconds to go
and miami can run it down
out of bio against green eight seconds
bam facing up gonna run it down he goes
with it
at obaya for the win
what a shot
you don't like those pull-ups jimmy
butler how about now
[Applause]
nothing soft about that final foray to
the basket
by ben adebayo he heard what jimmy
butler said
he heard every word and he fixed it
this afternoon richard and he just holds
it 10 seconds taking his time
just this was literally perfect get to
your shot
ball goes through zero's on the clock
don't give the brooklyn nets an
opportunity that is just confidence this
is this man just growing
right before our eyes taking his time
getting the shot that he wants and let
me tell you
to be in the building to see the fans
standing up and cheering
this environment is just unmatched
i tell you what when you look at the
final analysis of this richard
what bam adebayo and the rest of the
heat did today without
their connector their leading scorer
jimmy butler
their leading rebounder